us to ease sanctions on Venezuelan oil
for Freer presidential election
interesting these three stories I'll
combine them together and I'll give it
to Tom very interesting here the Biden
Administration in Venezuela this is from
wapo Washington Post the Biden
Administration and Venezuelan president
maduro's government have reached a
breakthrough deal in which the US will
ease sanctions on molan oil industry in
exchange for commitment from the
authoritarian regime to hold a
competitive internationally monitored
presidential election in 2024 the relief
and sanctions will be announced once an
AG assigned including commitments by the
Venezuelan government to ensure a fair
vote under the agreement Maduro has
agreed to process for lifting bans on
opposition candidates running uh in its
elections it's also com uh includes
commitments to maduro's government to
accept International election electoral
observations and open media access for
elections actually very very interesting
let me continue with the other two
stories Exon Mobile buying Pioneer
Natural Resources for nearly $60 billion
in its biggest deal in De case this is a
forb story
okay this is a forb story in this story
you see uh uh Exon uh uh set to acquire
Pioneer Natural Resources a 60 billion
all stock deal marking the largest deal
for Exon since it's merging with Mobile
in 19 late 1990s the acquisition will
acquire will value Pioneer at $253 a
share with Pioneer shareholders
receiving approximately 2.32 shares of
Exon Mobile for each share they own the
acquisition will give Exon Mobile a
Pioneer share 850 ,000 net acres in the
perian peran basan in West Texas
effectively doubling its output in the
region which accounted for 18% of all
natural gas and last but not least
lithium Discovery in US volcano could be
the biggest deposit ever found uh uh a
significant lithium deposit has been
identified in a volcanic crater along
the Nevada Oregon border potentially
containing between 20 to 40 million tons
of lithium metal which surpasses
previous deposits found in Bolivia the
discovery carries substantial Global
implications affecting lithium prices
supply chain security and geopolitical
Dynamics in the lithium Market mining
operations are projected to commence in
2026 aiming to extract lithium from the
claystone in an energy efficient and low
assd consumption manner Tom why do these
stories matter to the average American
we've been talking about the Middle East
and the Middle East is where there's a
lot of energy and the US has been a net
natural gas export
this increases our independence and
increases our ability to stand on the
world stage and to support Canada and
other people with energy needs so take a
look Venezuela Venezuela is right across
the gulf
from galvaston and Houston Texas where
we have giant refineries down there and
by the way so Venezuela it's it's sort
of comical hey if you promise promise
promise to be good tonight I'll give you
ice cream okay if you promise to have
fair and open elections in Venezuela and
stop knocking off opposition candidates
tell you what I'll take off the
sanctions on men your Venezuelan oil
member Venezuela is a member of everyone
everyone OPC OPEC yes they're the
they're the redheaded stepchild way
across the Atlantic Ocean and so that
brings Venezuelan oil here so that we
can take advantage of that Exxon buys up
this so that they could do and you've
heard it before you hear when the uh
conservative candidates say it what
should our energy policy be drill baby
drill well guess what Exxon just found
more places to drill baby drill cuz West
Texas WTI when you see in the Wall
Street Journal uh the average price for
you know light sweet crude Saudi Arabia
and for WTI Crude WTI is West Texas
intermediate and the peran Basin is this
giant giant Basin over there Midland
Odessa Texas where we have all this crew
so this is ex on getting access to even
more crude why is this important well to
get the prices for gas artificially down
about a year ago Joe Biden drained
What's called the Strategic petroleum
Reserve that's where we keep oil that if
there's a major Calamity maybe it's
weather maybe it's a hurricane that
ticks out Galveston you you don't know
what it could be but that was supposed
to be the place that we dip to it in a
time of emergency instead what he did he
was trying to drop the price gas um
artificially on the short-term basis and
people said you know you shouldn't be
doing this and now you have to refill it
so this is all part of of further
further American Energy Independence and
America as an energy power the
globalists don't want us to be an energy
power they want us to be dependent
that's why the greens line up with the
globalists to say oh don't don't drill
no pipelines and don't go into anoir
anoir basically is Drilling in Alaska
where there's a ton of oil well ladies
and gentlemen so this is what this is
all about this is whose Victory is this
this is a victory for United States
energy Independence that's great and
finally and Biden is doing what Trump
was doing with Venezuela why shouldn't
they be allowed to take their oil over
to us why don't we buy it but I'm
telling you it's all signs of every
policy that was working under Trump
Biden is finally realizing if you want
to get reelected you got to use those
policies cuz that's exactly what's
important to America wall oil
Independence you're seeing all these
stories secure well they're not doing
the Border Side but by the way by the
way the lithium Discovery is an
unexpected good news for the American
that's fantastic news because the how
does musk feel about that how does musk
feel about that uh he's he's been in
he's taking an exceptionally long shower
this morning is he launching a missile
he needed a big cold shower because he's
really happy about this because it means
we don't have to rely over time as this
becomes is this discover becomes mined
and available for sale it means you
don't have to rely on on China Chile or
very expensive lithium extraction from
seawater to get this heavy mineral that
you need to make batteries for electric
vehicles and there's a lot more to it
those batteries that you see Tesla cells
that go on the wall of garages that
could basically power the house for a
day and a half those that's a big part
of it too all about less Reliance
globally and this is exactly the stuff
that Trump would have been on top of
quick antidote for you Tom cuz great
explanation I appreciate that you said
how does this affect America well I'll
tell you how this affects my life and
affects our lives here in South Florida
so uh you may be familiar that in the
1980s and even prior to that there was
uh the Cuban uh entrance into Miami
basically Cubans helped build Miami
along with a lot of um local Jewish
community and and you know there's
something called Little Havana and cocho
and the there's a major major Cuban
presence in Miami BB Roso there you go
so uh slowly but surely uh Little Havana
and everything that's going on has sort
of been uh shifting towards what I call
Little karakas because uh that's the
capital of Venezuela Venezuelans are
pouring into legally speaking pouring
into Miami and and basically setting up
shop in Miami and saying we ain't going
back to freaking Venezuela that's great
that there's diplomatic relations kind
of going on the oil the sanctions
everything going on right there but
here's the one thing should know when
the Cubans first came here uh they were
anti-communist antisocial anti- Fidel
Castro and they voted with the
Republican party with Reagan and and
socially shed up that block what's
happening right now I know we talk about
the open borders and sort of the Latin
American countries in Mexico pouring in
and basically under the Democratic guys
of remember who let you in don't forget
these people who are basically leaving
the Maduro regime via um Chavez regime
uh will definitely be remembering uh the
Socialist Communist lifestyle uh and
remember that when they vote for most
likely Republicans in the upcoming
election assuming they're allowed to
vote so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right
here